taking action to address racism in the
clark county school district
the board of trustees agreed to start
working on an anti-racism policy during
their work session this morning and this
all follows various racial incidents
over the last couple of years including
racial cyber bullying
that happened at arbor view high school
kristin drummond now has the latest
trustees only having a conversation on
wednesday
no vote was taken because this is seen
as a starting point
gathering information and views of board
members about this topic
we have to look at this in a
problem-solving mode
working to develop an anti-racism policy
it's not really an elephant in the room
anymore
it's a it's bigger than an elephant and
it's something that's not going away
ccsd trustees share ideas to possibly
create an
action plan and make it official soon i
think it's important to do it while we
reopen schools
effort that akiko cooks and jonte
marshall welcome
this policy should have been in place a
very long time ago the duo are
co-founders of no racism in schools
1865 a campaign focusing on race related
matters on campuses
the group kicked off the initiative
hashtag write the policy wednesday
and plan to submit recommendations to
trustees it will include
consequences it will include assessments
it will include
core measurement values that will allow
for schools to be assessed
we actually do have this in our
anti-bullying policy in fact it's on the
very first page
trustee katie williams referencing the
document during the work session
it does list race and color and includes
the state laws about cyber bullying and
bullying
we already do cover it it's already
there and if it's not
being enforced that's not necessarily a
board issue but this is
probably an individual school issue do
you think the anti-bullying policy
goes far enough it does not there is no
specifics in terms of assessments of the
schools
and who are at risk bullying is much
different than racism
trustees want to get community feedback
they encourage engagement
to address disparities we're ready to
come to the table
trustees linda cavazos and irene cepeda
plan to study
other districts anti-racism policies
including in washoe
reporting in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now kristin thank you
trustee
ford suggested a timeline and includes
the board signing a resolution to fight
racism and develop a policy
talk with equity groups and then approve
that policy by early summer specifically
june